what are you most interested in reading
about
oh i mostly read i read a lot of
environmental non-fiction but
uh basically just like things about
climate about the environment just
whatever else um i mean i have a i have
a non-profit that supports solar
projects around the world basically like
environmental nonprofit
and so
that kind of i founded that sort of as a
result of a lot of different reading and
i mean we've been talking about the
expeditions and travel and all that i
mean it's hard
not to go on trips like that and feel
like you should be doing something
useful i feel like there's a part of me
that's like obviously
climate change is happening and then
there's another part of me that's like
i've watched videos where climate change
happens on a macro level
in ebbs and flows in history of the
world and like what if you're on a rise
does that is that is that part of it um
then there's other people that don't
think it's happening at all like what is
the reality of it from your perspective
well it's not even from my perspective i
think this is an example where you can
say there is an objective reality i mean
it's like yeah like the climate is
changing i mean it's just
you know how quickly to what extent it's
like yeah scientists still quibble over
some details but it's like climate
change is reality and it's and it's
happening
you know the whole macro scale stuff
basically doesn't
apply to the scale of change that we're
experiencing you know for for your line
of work you're not like in nature quite
as much but um dude i'm killing nature i
killed you yeah that's true
fuel as fast as i can the more fuel i
burned the faster i went so i was not in
the uh most conscientious form of
uh form of work yeah totally totally
well you know never never too late to uh
to change that
over the course of of my life you know i
can
physically see how forests have changed
in california how glaciers have receded
you know it's like or you know i was
talking about patagonia i've done four
or five expeditions there just in the
last six years you know some of the
glaciers have receded enough that you
now hike in different ways to the
mountains that you know like you used to
hike around the south side of the lake
now you hike around the north side of
the lake because the lake is twice as
big because the glaciers receded so much
you know and so when you see
that kind of change happening at that
kind of scale you know because
you know it's easy to be like oh macro
changes you know like yosemite used to
be glaciated and then the glaciers were
treated and you're like yeah they did
over thousands of years not over the
course of one human lifespan you know
basically it's like if you can
physically see change yourself
it's like you know that that the
timeline is totally out of control you
know it's like that's kind of that's why
i find it surprising that there's so
much climate denial
and actually i mean more so in the us
than than the rest of the world but it's
surprising because even if you're like
the most staunch climate denier it's
like you can see that the the flowers in
your garden bloom at different times
than they did when you were a kid you
know like wildfire season in california
is like completely different scale than
it was even 10 or 20 years ago
what are what are the things that need
to be done to really make a difference
and you know i mean i feel like me
driving a
you know a car that doesn't burn
gasoline and then battery powered is an
option but maybe it's the big you know
factory down the road that is like you
know my car is a whisper on the wind
compared to something like that so like
what are the what are the big things
that are really going to move the needle
well that's i mean that's the challenge
i mean there's always the the sort of
contrast between personal lifestyle
changes versus policy sort of issues
right i mean i think that in the us
there's always been a focus on personal
change we're like what should you be
doing like you should you know drive
green like go electric or go you know
drive a hybrid or things like that like
you know you should turn down your
thermostat things like that you know
basically like limit your impact and
that all makes sense and i think you
know people should at least think about
those things and do what they can
but the most important things are the
policy things i mean like voting you
know like making sure that the
government is steering the ship in the
right direction basically
you know it's like you can make certain
lifestyle choices basically if new homes
aren't built with natural gas hookups
then lo and behold nobody's burning
natural gas i think it's important that
that the default choices
get greener i actually i personally sort
of don't like the putting the onus on on
individual action because the reality is
that most people in the us like don't
have the bandwidth and the energy and or
even the finances to like make the green
choice all the time it's like
i think what needs to be done is is that
the the default choices need to be made
a little bit greener you know so like
building codes you know like slightly
denser uh communities with public
transportation let's say or like
you know i mean if new homes are
required to
be net zero so like produce their own
power so they have solar they don't have
gas hookups things like that it's like
those are kind of obvious like
relatively easy things that are put into
code yeah that wind up making an
individual's life much much greener
without them actually having to put any
effort into it probably i'm going to
guess the snag that comes along with
that is that
it's probably going to cost some money
you know like
some of that
some of that though is the upfront cost
is a little bit higher but then the life
cycle cost is much lower you know the
thing with solar and stuff like that
it's like yeah it costs a little bit
more ahead of time but then you don't
have a utility bill let's say yeah and
so you know over the over the lifetime
of ownership it's actually you save
quite a bit of money
but it's just you know there's a higher
hurdle to clear but that's where that's
where smart policy decisions need to
come in you know it's like that's where
there's a place for government and like
tax breaks and things like that and you
know because those are the kinds of
things where i'm like it's not
fundamentally harder to build you know
like not having gas hookups like can be
cheaper actually i mean you know when
you put a new natural gas hookup into a
building it costs like 1500 to like hook
it up to the to the meter and everything
it's like it's not fundamentally more
expensive it's just that it's slightly
different and people aren't used to
doing it that way and you're you know
it's just not the status quo for a
reason yeah bill mckibben is like a
really renowned environmental activist
who's like worked with 350.org a bunch
and
he's written a ton of books about the
environment in different ways but um but
basically the the premise of earth was
that we're already living on an earth
that isn't the earth that we remember
from childhood which is kind of what i
was actually just talking about where
like when my grandparents talked about
what the world is like like we don't
live in that world anymore like they're
already you know more than 100 parts per
million carbon in the atmosphere more
than there were when our grandparents
were kids it's like and that literally
changes every aspect of the earth you
know like the ocean is more acidic which
means that the shellfish like mollusks
and things make more brittle shells and
like eggs don't form the same way it's
like we've literally changed every
ecosystem on earth already you know i
think also about regenerative farming
and i think about um you know hearing
from a few different people that i've
interviewed that we have
60 or 70 harvests left in our soil and
you know
we're just treating our planet
pretty crappy and you know regenerative
farming i think is one of those things
too that
is you know more efficient over time but
you know
you have to learn how to do it and that
to me is another example of like policy
things where you're like why isn't that
the default you know it's like why not
just be like like everything should be
that way you're like it's if it's a
smarter way to do it and it's better
long term it's like why not just do that
you know it's like it's easy to imagine
a world that's like that's better in a
lot of ways you're like why not
implement some of those things